so I have this thing called the violence
scale which is totally arbitrary I made
it up but you know the violent scales 1
through 10 scale every number in between
0 and 10 is risk I come in at a zero as
soon as I know it's going to be violent
and that switch is flipped I go to 10
because if they go to a higher number
before I do I'm dead
[Music]
goodbye
thank you brother thank you for for for
being here oh man thanks for having me
dude come on man I I uh I really want to
bring folks on that that I just feel
um have really walked the walk don't
just talk about it and um are humble and
kind and honest and uh courageous and um
you're sort of um
I can't really think of somebody better
uh than you you grew up in Bakersfield
uh you went into the military I want to
talk to you about Bakersfield I went to
the military uh Special Forces Delta and
Ranger
um you got wounded uh overseas you know
you were you were both the subject and
the star of an incredible documentary
made by a very dear friend of both of
ours you know the person that that kind
of attaches you and I and is Rick Wall
yeah they're like no words for how much
that guy means to me and like the chance
he took on me and um how he's made me
kind of believe in myself and one thing
I can tell you about Rick is like
anybody in Rick's orbit is just solid as
[__] yeah and and just like who's Rick
wall and like who does like what does he
mean to you for lack of a better term
he's just great at everything he does
and and I actually the first thing I'm
gonna actually say is it's not related
to the industry or or work but
he is the best father I've ever seen you
know how so
um you know he doesn't he he strikes the
perfect balance he's got two twin twin
boys but he strikes the perfect balance
between in in of course my humble
opinion uh between treating them as kids
and adults
you know like he gives them the the kid
experience in leeway yet at the same
time he doesn't he doesn't [__] him
he doesn't lie to him you know what I
mean he very much treats them
um as many adults but but also also kids
and and there's a good balance between
that and and again if there's any
Testament to to how good of a father he
is
you know meet the kids right you know
they're amazing they are um and oh yeah
and you obviously have and and
um
and then of course uh like everything
else he does you know as a filmmaker as
a writer as a director as you know
everything he does he's just a machine
there's nothing on a film set that he
doesn't know Rick is such a soldier of
authenticity you know like he made a
movie felon was sort of the first first
I mean was the first movie he made about
you know Corcoran prison riots and the
Gladiator games and he like literally
went and like basically became a pro
like a parole officer and basically two
years yeah and like did that time and
you know when you know he did snitch he
did shot caller those are the movies
that I did with him that we did with him
but you know he
you know he gains access into a world he
craves authenticity he provides the
infrastructure and and and and opens the
door into the real world in a way that
no one else that I've ever worked with
you you know does and um you know that's
kind of where you came in right I mean
he he kind of came to you I mean when
did he first come to you we met through
a mutual friend and he was writing a
movie a military movie uh we had lunch
at the Grove and I was like 2000
nine something like that and uh just
right away you know we started talking
and we worked on that script for a
couple months and then started work on
another one uh neither got made but
after working on that script and just
talking about what I knew
um or from my experience he uh invited
me to lunch one day which it was weird
and uh B's like uh sat me down he's like
hey uh so I got some time before I
forget what he had to do but he's like
you know I've always wanted to do a
documentary and you know sitting there
eating oh cool
um and he's like and you know a lot of
the stuff that we've been talking about
I I don't really think people like know
that message
um like would you want to you want to do
one and me being me I was like yeah okay
sure yeah sounds good yeah no idea I was
getting into this five-year very
personal process uh and you know so we
we made that over five years and uh
and again his it is it is what it is
because of his
um
just intuition on on on The Human
Experience and and uh he's able to take
any and all authenticity that's maybe
that authenticity is specific for prison
or specific for the military or whatever
but he has a way of Translating that
specific authenticity into a universal
human authenticity and experience and
that's I mean that documentary can you
just tell us a little bit about the
documentary and yeah yeah so it's called
Uh that which I love destroys me which
um is really a bastardized uh Latin
quote that kind of reversed because it
made more sense to me but um it portrays
to a degree a solution
um or you know like us overcoming these
obstacles and what's interesting for me
is what I realized in hindsight was the
documentary was really the beginning of
my actual real journey that was the
entire documentary was really just me
figuring out the problem and it was at
the end of the documentary when that was
over with that I really uh started
working on the solution whereas if you
watch the documentary you'd think that
it's you know totally encapsulated so
the most progress you will have as a
person and probably in your life is a
doing the things you don't want to do
and be
addressing the parts of your personality
that you bury and hide we lie we lie to
no one more than we lie to ourselves you
said something earlier about how like we
are we are sort of in in evolutionary
biology I think you're saying how like
we are we're literally like designed to
only address and and worry about and
take care of what's going on right in
front of us right now but right now
we're inundated with so much more like
extraneous [__] information how do
you Whittle that down
uh you know for me again I mean the the
I guess for lack of a term the theory or
the The Sciences uh evolutionary
psychology and it basically says that
um
you know within Evolution that we are
obviously Evolution takes time so we're
not designed for right now we haven't
evolved to right now we're evolved to
thousands of years ago as Hunter uh
gatherers societies and when you start
studying how hunter-gatherer societies
worked and then you start and then you
apply
a lot of problems of today and then
apply it to that you go I mean there's
not a Smoking Gun but it's pretty
obvious that the truth is is pretty
apparent
um and and on that note with you know if
you if you look at 100 gatherer Society
it was generally and some scientists is
going to be like he's full of [__] but
you know it's like 50 to 100 people was
you know like a 100 gatherer tribe or
whatever and you know with without uh
obviously the internet radio
communication if if somebody from that
tribe told you something it was
important to your
probably your daily survival in that
moment hey there's a you know a buffalo
coming in to freaking you know and
ravaging the camp whatever I don't
making stuff up but but you know what I
mean like that that was relevant
anything you heard
anything was relevant because it was
relevant to that group that group is
your survival and the only thing that
you could possibly hear by definition of
the lack of Technology at the time was
something relevant to that 50 to 100
people
nowadays
um we're constantly inundated with
information
from you know not I mean everyone's like
ah 24-hour news Cycles it's like no no
forget 24-hour news Cycles try you know
how many texts a day do you get you know
how many emails a day do you get we are
overloaded with information all of those
information streams for the most part
are designed to make it as easy as
humanly possible to absorb them yes and
humans by nature take the easy path
right so to actually turn those things
off and point yourself in a different
direction takes an amazing amount of
mental strength now and stamina totally
and we don't ever talk about that we're
asking a lot of people to now look in
the face of that information stream and
choose a different Behavior it's it's
unbelievably hard to do it is because
because of that wiring of your brain
going but what if one piece is important
what if I do need to know one piece you
know and and
um
everyone's well I'd say most people have
done it now where you you know you know
what I'm going to go away for the
weekend and I'm not going to have my
phone on
and the proof's in the pudding well at
least I'll turn it off for five minutes
but you know what I'm saying like how do
you feel if you had your if if you're
out in the middle of nowhere and you had
no reception for a whole day other than
the anxiety of oh I gotta get a hold of
this person like how do you feel it's
[__] great it's great it's relaxing
yeah it's because that's what you're
designed for yeah you're designed for
um and I think it's actually Tim
ferriss's term the low information diet
um now that I'm remembering but um it's
uh I've done it now for uh
I don't know six months like I don't
have I mean granted there's been news
things where you know like
it's been like four days well you know
Trump lost right like yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's certain things where people
are like you don't know about this and
I'm like no and they're like oh my God
and yeah you feel like oh maybe I'm
behind but all right do I really need to
know that yeah no yeah you know I I
don't and and not to say and I'm gonna
put something out there that's
it's going to be controversial but
we just need to care less
I think that's the problem everyone's
pushing caring more more more you mean
like politically and like in the
tribalism like I'm just like I I mean
if this it's a collective push to care
more about everything and everyone and
the reality is the opposite the reason
that's going to make you miserable by
definition is this a fact is
I can care about you I can I can care
about you to level 100 but I can't
control or change you right so all the
things that you care about that you
can't control
they're just gonna make you miserable
yeah because you care about them but you
can't control them the only thing that
you can control is you if we all cared
about ourselves and truly cared about
ourselves and controlled ourselves we'd
be happier because
we can actually actuate change and then
we wouldn't need to care and push others
to do other things because everyone
would be and again I'm you know this is
a uh obviously a utopian idea that's not
possible but I'm saying theoretically
um
the easiest way to be miserable is to
try and control everything around okay
it'll fundamentally fail okay always
does and and that's another thing I had
to accept is every aspect of myself
uh even when I switched and was like
okay I can only control me okay I'll
control me and I started working on
control me and then
I also learned hey there's some things
you can't control about yourself it
seems like so much of your life like you
ha you just are like this self-motivated
self-driving like I don't quit like
[__] bring on the pain whatever like
when did you know you want to be in the
military like how did that come back
well it's it's funny you said because I
I don't feel like I ever had a decision
it was something that I wanted to do for
as long as I could remember I mean I was
probably I mean I could show you
pictures of me when I was you know five
in full camo like I mean that was that
was always who I was it was uh it was
something I had to do from as early as I
can remember is it in the family no no
no uh I mean other grandfather in World
War II like everyone's but um no my dad
was in the military it just it was
something I just
I just had this innate like I have to do
this I had a Ranger and a special forces
poster on my wall uh as a kid and and
um you know like I mean I probably
played guns you know you know played War
uh [__] every day literally every day
and and um
it was just so a part of who I was when
when I got to that point you know
um it really wasn't
it wasn't really a choice it was just
something I felt I had to do when you
got old enough to remember it
when it became conscious so like
post-childhood before signing up
do you remember thinking about
the structure of military the
camaraderie and team of military the
patriotism like what was it at that
point do you have some conscious memory
then of what the driver was that excited
you to to join yeah uh yeah and again
you know I'll be honest even though
it'll raise some eyebrows
um I want to kill bad guys
straight up you know and and again now
the term bad guy you know is yeah don't
even be started on that but you know I
I looked at it as a kid you know I was
fascinated with uh with the Middle Ages
and nights and Samurai you know
um the code of honor and and helping
those who couldn't help themselves and
that's to me Special Operations was the
current equivalent of that what was your
sort of experiences if any with violence
with real violence before joining the
military
um you know other than I was pretty uh
I was pretty good as a kid
um
I could talk my way out of just about
anything I mean I I got in fights but
um but generally I could talk my way out
of a fight
um
unless you know there was sometimes I
didn't want to talk my way out of it but
you know that was also 80s you know time
where you know kids could punch each
other in the face and it wasn't a big
deal yeah
um and uh you know it
I never saw
um
I'll say the word true violence I would
say as a child I never saw like true
violence
um
it wasn't until I was in that I saw like
what I would call real violence but
you know I
but I'll say this and again sounds weird
but
but I wanted to see it
like I just had this I wanted to see
every facet of
of the human animal animal like I wanted
to see I wanted to see the extremes you
know I want to see how far this can go I
want to see I want to see uh
I want to see the animal Unleashed yep
you know you knew you knew it was always
Rangers
uh well originally I wanted you know I
mean I was a huge and and I'll just say
this now because it it'll probably come
up later but the two things there's two
things I want to do as a kid one
obviously in militaries I've been saying
the other was I was fascinated by film I
probably watched Star Wars 200 times as
a kid I broke up I broke the VHS tape
like oh [__]
um
and uh so I watched Rambo probably over
a hundred times so I wanted to be a
Green Beret yeah
um when I joined uh you couldn't get a
Green Beret contract that didn't start
until actually after 9 11. so I was like
well what's the you know what can you
guarantee me an opportunity for and they
said Ranger so uh that's that's how I
went to and I obviously I knew about
Rangers and I had studied all the all
the special operations for us is um
people like when should we become a seal
and I'm like uh mainly because I can't
swim
kind of remove that one from the and
people were like no everyone can some no
I but I seriously don't float like you
just explain to people that can you just
explain you know Rangers versus delta
and like how you did but like what what
that is and what that process was like
yeah Rangers are you know it's a special
operations unit um but it's for for lack
of a better term uh
a starter you know you can come in off
the streets you know so you got people
that are very senior that have been
there 10 years you know and you've done
all kinds of things and then you got you
know 18 19 year olds straight off the
street
um that that then have to get
indoctrinated into that program and and
really when I went through the the the
selection process was called Rip
literally was Ranger indoctrination
program which was they just smoked the
[__] out of you and and just crushed you
every day and
the people that quit didn't make it and
the people that didn't quit made it you
know I'm oversimplified what's the
percentage there you know I I don't know
really it's I mean you know probably 60s
70s whatever but
um mostly physical or mental
um
well both uh
most people can handle
the body is always stronger than the
Mind always always always always so uh
it's really a process of essentially
making something
physical also mental you know once
you're once your mind is is at that
level of uh zero [__] like it's it's
hard to destroy a person who really just
is at that point where you know they're
they're Zen and you know they're just
I I don't care what you do to me
um because it'll end
you know and anyways and and so uh you
go through that process and and and you
get there and and then you go through
you know a train up process and what I
loved about ranger battalion uh is that
it is in a it's a special operations
unit but it's also an elite infantry
unit
um so for me you learn
infantry tactics and
I'll I'll take a Pepsi challenge to
anyone that disputes this but despite
what anyone says all Special Operations
all combat CQB like the coolest CQB ever
it's just infantry combat in a confined
space the the the fundamental concepts
of of combat haven't changed for ever
you know as long as it's humans doing it
whether you're holding an ax a spear a
sword or a gun or a bow and arrow it's
it's a game of angles and you know train
all these different things so I love
that I learned the basis the the the
beginnings of of basic infantry skills
and Elite infantry skills
um and then later when I went to the
tier one counter terrorism unit
I had a great understanding of those
Basics and then you know obviously they
take it to another level but um anything
Advanced is just a master a master of
the basics and I would argue
you know where to cheat the basics and
like where to just yeah step one two
three I'll just go from one to three and
that timeline like when you when you did
that and you made that switch had you
already had you already been in combat
yeah I'd been to Afghanistan so my my
first uh year as a ranger I was my first
job was an assistant machine gunner
which is like the worst job ever you
don't even have a gun like I had a
pistol and a [__] bag full of ammo
and barrels it was horrible in a tripod
weighed like 70 something pounds his
worst job ever but
um
actually I say it was the worst job ever
but it actually really taught me
something which is
taught me to just suck it up and carry
weight and just carrying weight over
long distances up hills
again that that's a perfect example of
people would always say you know rocking
heavy weight is is physical and I'm like
no it's mental because your body wants
to quit every second because you got 100
pounds in your back it feels like it's
trying to crush you like a foot and an
aluminum can
um but your body can go for 100 miles
the Mind wants to quit within the first
10 steps so it taught me that and then I
became a sniper and and I did that until
I left how did 911 sort of like play
into all that for you at that time um
actually that's a that's a great
question because I was uh and this kind
of goes to what you and I were talking
about earlier off camera of you know I I
had done I forget how long I had been in
by the time 9 11 happened but um I was
right in my like re-enlistment window
and before 9 11 I was like I'm getting
out like you know I joined to I joined
to go to war like I I mean not that
there was a war going on when I joined
but you know I was optimistic
um but uh
and and I just was gonna get out and I
don't even remember what my plan was but
but I was going to get out oh actually
it was going to come to Hollywood so
then 911 happened and uh there was a lot
unknown at that time uh third ranger
battalion went before we did so you know
we didn't know we thought the war was
going to be over so I said look if we
get orders to deploy to Afghanistan I
will literally re-enlist that day until
then I'm not re-enlisting because I'm
not going to re-enlist and then the war
is over and you know obviously little
little did we know at that time but
um you know when when you had uh you
know I mean the control over most of the
country happened happened relatively
quickly so you know we thought it'd be
over with so
um we got orders to Afghanistan and and
I re-enlisted for six years uh with the
intent of of going to the the other unit
or trying to go to the other unit
um my first deployment to Afghanistan
was uh
uh after
um operation on Anaconda was actually
also we switched out the people that
were at Robert's Ridge which is a
a horrible uh kind of like a Black Hawk
Down scenario except it was a chinook
but
um
it was when they had pushed Anaconda
pushed all of all of the uh the Taliban
to
um to the Pakistani border area so my
deployment my first deployment was
basically building the out stations
along uh the Pakistani border which is
now you know corrugal Valley all those
places that you know now we know the
names of that that was when we first
started building those out stations wow
so it was uh it was it was in
it was very interesting because it was
because war was new
it was like Vietnam it was crazy what
was your day-to-day like there I mean
can you can you take us through it a
little bit uh well one day I just happen
to remember and uh so I was literally
sleeping in a gopin
um but one day we we had to dig mortar
pits so and again you know like now I
look back and like oh we should have
known but we had to dig mortar pits and
so we had like I don't know six blocks
of six blocks of C4 you know I mean
you're we're in combat like go grab the
C4 cool you know no one it's not like
anyone's tracking it on a piece of paper
right right so we go grab six Suboxone
C4 we we put sandbags on it we Tamp it
and we because we have to blow this
mortar pit the mortar pits I forget how
deep but it's got to be like four feet
deep I forget and pretty big we blow
this up we walk over there and I'm not
joking it looked like a little kid had
taken a scooper and scooped like three
scoops out of the ground and I'm like
you gotta be [__] me like that's how
the train is is fierce there wow but
I'll never forget just look at that and
going that was C4 right yeah yeah
um and we eventually figured it out but
um it was it was just at that time
combat was so new that
everyone was just
figuring out what it was for lack of a
better term and we were at that time you
know as a sniper I was a sniper team
leader we would go on four-man
uh we'd go out for four days and stay
out in the mountains for four days just
you know or like a like um
uh what's called a move uh Lone Survivor
or that type you know we'd go and you
know report on movement and all these
different things and it was just four of
us out there and looking back now
knowing obviously a lot more about
combat and warts like man we were
hanging it out there it was four Dudes
you know what I mean like if you had a
force of you know whatever it's not a
lot you could do but at that time it was
just a now there's no way they would
hell I was in e
it was like 23 years old or something
like that and I was in charge like
there's no way they would let some dudes
out of the wire you know yeah I go for
four days like tell us what happens like
just uh
at that time you know it was just it was
just new so fast forward a little bit
you know you take those feelings you had
when the war started and being out there
with those four guys and go through the
sort of Time Warp a year two years
forward in your time how did your
mindset change and the way you felt
about those same things evolved in the
time that you were there
well so part of the
I'm going to use the word problem
um was like I didn't really
like I had a great time in Afghanistan
like I had a [__] good time it was
fun because it was what I wanted to do
it was I wanted to go to combat like I
wanted to [__] be buried in mud with
a [__] knife like a you know Rambo
man and um
sorry I actually really enjoyed it and
um
and then even when you know so I get
back from Afghanistan and I basically I
worked with the unit that I went to I
got to work with them in Afghanistan
because they didn't have a sniper team
so we got attached to them and uh and I
was like okay like this is this is the
movie cool [__] like this is what I want
to be doing what were they doing
it was more that you know they they were
developing their own I'll say it this
way they were able to develop their own
Intel and develop their own targets and
you know what I mean like they were able
to create their own missions yeah didn't
come from somebody else going hey
there's guys over they were going hey
let's see what's actually there this is
there okay hey let's go hit it you know
they were so like we were talking about
before free thinkers
got people who are intuitive uh it could
take initiative exactly they were
developing their own Intel they were
they were uh seeing everything they were
willing to go out there
um uh you know uh firsthand and see what
the Intel actually was not what other
people said it was and and
um and I just like again all all combat
has to be driven by off of off of some
kind of Intel or it's just you know
that's how you get that's how you get
killed
um and so I was like this is this is
really their autonomy was just really uh
like you said their ability to free
think and not be controlled by the big
army system I was like that's cool that
that's that's what I want to do and so
when I got back from that trip I I uh
put in a packet and I went through that
whole process which took about a year
um and then I got assigned to the unit
there
um and then I was there for
um I don't know how long maybe six
months before we deployed to Iraq
um you know and and I remember this is a
funny thing I remember being in training
and and
everyone's like Iraq I'm like we're not
going to Iraq that ain't gonna happen
like Afghanistan there's no way the guy
firmly was like Iraq's not gonna happen
and then when we invaded Iraq I was like
oh [__] well wrong about that you know
and then you know have six months later
or whatever I'm I'm going to uh you know
flying to to Iraq to uh
um
my the first well got to Baghdad and
then we were in Fallujah but
um
and then Fallujah was
flusian 2004 I mean it was
it was [__] World War II
like
I I
can't describe it other than it it was a
war war you know when you're in
Afghanistan you know yeah I've seen
Specter you know hammering stuff and I'd
seen you know I'd seen
things but like
a freaking tank coming in and shooting
in a city yeah a building like we were
calling casts on buildings in the city I
mean Street to Street yeah that
that was war to me and you know I I was
like holy [__] like this is on you know
Cobra gunships coming in and just
dumping stuff I mean that was like wow
um
and it really
again it was and it sounds
it is what it is that's what I wanted
like you know I watched Rambo and I
wanted PTSD right I don't know what kind
of [__] up kid that makes me but I I
wanted to be [__] up like Rambo I
wanted to go to the town grab the M60
and get in a fight with the [__]
Sheriff that's what I wanted right right
you know when you got wounded did it
change any of that mentality that you
had or did you
want to get back to the fight did you
miss the fight how did you feel
differently after you died didn't change
until probably the last three years
I I can honestly say if there's anything
that's surprised me it's that you know
10 years after being out you're like
well surely I'm surely it is what it is
at this point I'm not going to change my
mentality and just in the last two to
three years I see things
absolutely completely different
absolutely completely different and it's
and and now I see where like
a lot of older veterans get I I get it
and it and it's kind of
it's not kind of it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking because
it doesn't matter what you say like you
can't explain it
but one day they'll get there on their
own and then they too will want to
explain it to the younger version of
themselves but they can't and it's just
it's just it's just like watching all
these people that are
that you just you you know what's gonna
happen you know their future and but you
can't would flip that switch for you two
or three years and I don't know I I I've
thought about that I
tried to
I don't know
um it's
awareness of just
the overall and I don't mean this in any
you know uh conspiratorial sense but
like the overall system just the way
that human beings
have always been over time it's just the
way we are it's a cycle and and what's
interesting about that cycle is the
warrior cycle it's not new you know you
can it's been this way for thousands of
years and
um one thing that I think I don't know
if I said this in the documentary but
again I'll still use the the word or the
term PTSD even though I think it's more
complicated than that but you know back
uh
uh I'll let we'll say Braveheart great
movie Brave Hard Times okay Braveheart
times you know we're running at each
other and hitting each other with axes
you know and we're this close together
that that's pretty hardcore combat right
well yeah but also a freaking bomb
dropping and blowing up all of us that
we didn't even know the [__] airplane
was up there right and then now we're in
pieces
is that any more or less ruthless it's
about the same yeah the difference is
now we live a pretty good life not in
war
but back in Braveheart times even if you
weren't in combat life was [__] hard
right every time you want to eat you
were doing that yeah I mean kids died
you know in childbirth very common your
brother dies from dysentery literally
shits to death right common common so
back then life was this hard
combat was this hard now
combat's still the same
but life is so much easier and that
difference that Chasm that just has to
be [__] and that must have been so
insane to come back to and and and see
it's it's you it's like you're jumping
between two realities right and and that
difference to me is PTSD because you've
seen this other reality that you know
exists and then you come back to a place
that no one else has seen it it's like
an imaginary world you're like no no I'm
I'm telling you like some people are
capable of this and they're like oh no
people aren't capable
but again they wouldn't know and until
they've seen it and another thing that
you realize in combat is
I don't I don't care who you are
everyone has murder in them
everyone
absolutely everyone
and people are like well well well
the reason we do and again there's
exceptions to every rule don't get me
wrong but
of course we do
we're designed that way we're designed
it's literally a survival mechanism if
you know 200 years ago it's you know me
and you hand like yeah can you give me
an example of something that shocked the
[__] out of you or that like like a bad
example of somebody that you you
wouldn't think they had it in them or
you know I saw people's level of
ruthlessness on on you know some of
those people that are just such
you know the most innocent nice guy and
then you just see them being absolutely
ruthlessly violent and
it's surprising you know and but what's
worse is again I'm not that way by
nature and I remember in the beginning I
was like oh that's that's [__]
unnecessary I well I don't really I
don't really agree with that I I think
you should do the minimum amount
to to to get things done the minimum
amount of violence to get things done
and that's how I felt for the first
couple years
then I realized and then these people by
the way that I'm talking about were at
that time had done more trips were more
experienced than me and then I realized
over time
no there's
when it comes to
um so I have this thing called the
violence scale which is totally
arbitrary I made it up but you know the
violence scales one through ten scale
and you know for me back then it was
like you know start with one and if one
doesn't work you go to two and a two
doesn't work you go to three you know
and then once it works then you stop and
what I eventually learned is is that
every number in between 0 and 10 is risk
risk that you're taking on to go through
those numbers
for me to truly have no risk I come in
at a zero as soon as I know it's going
to be violent and that switch is flipped
I go to 10.
because if the reason is if they go to a
higher number before I do
I'm dead they went I lose so you you
learn over time you have to be
absolutely rude when it comes to
violence and it comes to that game
everything in between you know one and
nine is is just you opening yourself up
to lose
and and it goes like fighting and I'm
not talking about boxing or like real
fighting I always say and look I'm not a
martial artist but I always say first
rule of fighting same thing as the first
rule of gun fighting same thing as the
first world war cheat
there's no honor and death you know the
freaking first there's no rules no one
it's War [__] you like that's the
reality of it
um and it and it's a horrible reality
and the problem is is that
we're at a point where we can't do war
that way
for many reasons so there's this
ambiguity in this it's just we're doing
war with rules which
doesn't make any sense it would blow
people's minds how much risk we take as
as soldiers or you know Airmen you know
Navy whatever
um Marines to
you know when we know we shouldn't uh
because of politics essentially
puts a lot of pressure on very young
people though to be able to accurately
gauge 101 is even going to become a two
right and and talk about that challenge
a little bit because I imagine is you
got more experienced that was probably
an easier call to make but for an 18
year old out there for the first time
if you're looking at it as a one or a
ten you actually got to be really good
at figuring out when it's a two
and my guess is when you're not that
experienced that that's a pretty damn
hard call to make it it is and people
can't grasp
hey how much training it takes to go
into a room and there's a good guy and a
bad guy to only shoot the bad guy I mean
it's it's not only an unbelievable
amount of training it's an unbelievable
amount of time and on top of all that
you learn through the training process
it's also something in your head some
people can do it some people can't and
you don't really know till you're there
right you know you can train your ass
and talk about that I mean so you you
know you went through some of the most
extensive training possible how
different how prepared were you how
different is it when you actually get in
into the real thing
um you know it it's it's like you're
saying which is you know you don't
really
the selection process that we had and
and I'll not go into it but I'll say
this because it's unofficial this is
what I think it is is
because what it is what you're doing
you're like what the [__] does this have
to do with fighting Wars you know like
this doesn't make any sense you know and
now I look back and I go God it makes
it's so smart oh really yeah and again
not official this is what I think it is
what I think it is is it's designed to
find people
that can get instructions once
and figure it out
if they make a mistake they self-correct
they don't go down the rabbit hole of oh
well they just [__] they just
self-correct because it's all by
yourself you're alone almost the whole
time
um and the other thing is they learn
very quickly and they learn very quickly
from their mistakes
that's what I think it's designed for
because once you have that you can teach
them anything
I I want to ask you something else about
I'm asking so much [__] I want to ask
you man but I I want to ask you
something else about that Chasm when you
think about these things like what
you're talking about about the the
parallel between Brave hard times and
War in life and like how now it's like
everything in our life literally
everything is so easy one thing they
talk about is just Transportation just
like literally in World War II would
have taken a few weeks of just still
being around soldiers but like you know
now it's like literally the next day
you're home yeah and and I'm just
wondering your your situation as well
because your time there just kind of
came to an end correct because you were
wounded yeah and straight you know
literal to Germany within a day and then
back home took like a week but you know
I know Kevin Vance another guy that we
both love and have ultimate respect for
you know he talked about you know why
all one of the reasons he ultimately you
know got out was he was like look man I
would come home and I'd have to turn the
monster off yeah and then I'd go and I'd
have to turn the monster back on and and
it was just getting harder and harder to
make that
but for you in your psychology
you still had years you still were there
with these guys doing this thing for
years so so I imagine your monster
whatever it was for you is that that's
that's where you were at so do you do
you feel like that
as far as how whatever you want to call
it the PTSD like the the psychological
distress and and and torture that you
went through was that part of it do you
think that it was like the proximity was
taken like the rug was pulled out from
under you in a way
or do you think you were going to go
through that no matter what
I think I I was lucky in the sense that
my I had always
um
I had always compartmentalized My Life
um just for reasons of how I grew up you
know
um so I had always compartmentalize
things so it didn't really
it didn't really affect me as much as I
saw it affect others
in ways did that serve you I you know I
I also think again being very
forthcoming I also think I just have a
a little sociopathic
um
you know I've watched like every murder
documentary there is and I'm fascinated
by watching uh uh Psychopaths and you
know just psychopathy is is just
fascinating to me
um and I obviously very much have a
conscience and a funny story I was
talking to my therapist years ago and I
was I was like I'm worried I might be a
sociopath like because I have these
sociopath Tendencies and she goes
Tyler
if you're worried that you're a
sociopath you're not you're definitely
not a sociopath and I was like
I can't argue with that one yeah
I'm like how did I miss that one but
um but I definitely have this little
thing where
um and I'll give you a story and there's
nothing
I'm going to tell you the story and it's
going to sound
crazy but it's not crazy and that's why
I'm telling it
um we did this right on this house and
anyways so I can
I don't know
13 guys were shot I I can't remember and
um
and I had a digital camera and I had to
go take pictures of the uh of all of
them all the guys and ran it through the
Intel system blah blah blah and um I
went to this one guy he was in the
kitchen and uh
he was shot I don't know how many times
but at least eight not that I'm [__]
counting holes but
um but he wasn't dead and his head was
you know down and I got down there to
take the picture and when I got down
there I realized he wasn't dead and I
just kind of watched him and then I was
like oh [__] you know I think he's gonna
die
uh these are going to die right now and
I just sat there and I just I just
watched him and
I I literally did it it was it was
it was an experiment
like a human experience had nothing to
do with the military I was just like I
want to see what I like does it do
anything and
um no I didn't
just nothing it
it didn't mean anything to me and
what I realized is that in my head again
the little sociopathic quality is
once I put you in a you're a piece of
[__] category
I don't care if your whole house and
family burned down
that's just the way I am
up until that I'll be the greatest dude
ever like you all [__] die for you
but but once you are a piece of [__]
that affects you know does damage to
other people
you're [__] done but isn't that a
that must be a necessity of fighting an
award right I mean if you walk into
every situation second guessing every
single interaction you have while you're
out in the field as a soldier you know
talk about your risk Spectrum you're
pushing yourself way down the risk
Spectrum every single time right yeah
yeah but you do see there's varying
degrees of it like some people can still
can still do the job but they still can
have the awareness of kind of that human
interaction like oh you know this is
another human being whereas when I like
this guy
um
he
it wasn't that he wasn't a human being I
just didn't give a [__] like I knew it
was a piece of [__] I knew what he was
doing he was a horrible person and I'm
like I'm glad you're dying [__] you and
and it just didn't but but I didn't have
not only did I not have a sense of oh
that's sad but I also didn't have a
sense of all right one for the team I I
it was there was nothing I had
absolutely no feeling towards it and and
that was a
that was
it was kind of a it was weird for me and
I just kind of realized that's why later
you know these whole so when I watched
sociopaths I'm like okay I definitely
have that little quality to where I can
just shut off any empathy whatsoever
if I if I deem them as as a do you have
medical confirmation that you're not one
so you're good yeah well technically
it's just an opinion yeah yeah yeah
there you go they could get an expert to
counter it but hey is this has this
country gotten any better at helping
veterans with PTSD or is it status quo
oh that's a tough one um
it's definitely gotten better
um
it's gotten better in the sense that
the systems have gotten better
uh the problem that I see is is again
so there's a guy who I'll mention
um which you should talk to he's [__]
cool as [__] uh Sky Marcus Capone
started this uh [__] what's it called
okay he's gonna kill me but um he's as
big as Kevin you know they're like the
same size but he started this thing
where he basically uh it's all
alternative medicine and he takes guys
through this whole you know Ayahuasca I
began DMT it's all legit you know all
the stuff and I mean it has changed so
many people's lives and where I'm going
with this is
the system will always be the system you
know for free for people to think that
the VA is is is going to solve veteran
trauma and Veteran PTSD is is like
saying that the DMV does a good job of
freaking you know monitoring drivers you
know right no it's it's going to come up
to or it's going to come down to
us who has to figure it out we do is it
our responsibility well yeah
yeah yeah it is you can't say
at the same time you can't say you know
I believe in less government but then
also go hey the VA should fix it right
exactly you know and again I'm I'm not
talking politics but I'm saying
I'm not saying it should be up to us
what I'm saying is it is because
we're the ones who have experienced it
we're the ones who know intrinsically
What It Is by by our own feeling and
experience and it's just like the I told
one of the VA psychologists this I was
like you're telling me everything that
you've read it to be and I'm telling you
what it is
but because you have the degree you're
right and I'm wrong
right that makes no sense like that that
listen to me like I'm I I want help I'm
trying to help you help me but you're
fighting me on it
um and and so I think it's a test and I
I think the system has gotten better but
ultimately
the ultimate Way like this this thing
that Marcus Capone is doing is it's it's
Fringe it's out there ten years it won't
be out there it'll be normal but those
options at least exist they exist now
and they exist because some veteran
tried them or you know and and Marcus
has really been spearheading it but
um you know there's these this brainwave
treatment there's all kinds of these
things but and here's the worst part
all of them right now are uh the
brainwave thing uh Marcus's thing Marcus
is a former Deb group guy it's
the amount of time it will take for
those things to trickle down to a system
like the VA
it's just it's it's the government it's
a it's a bureaucracy it's a behemoth and
um that's why I say I I think it's up to
us to take care of our own because
um
it's just the system will never by
definition of what it is I mean I was a
very lonely kid I had [__] imaginary
friends you know uh
I was a very lonely kid and and opening
up my feelings got me hurt so I just
shut him off as a kid and um that was my
childhood and and that was safe for me
so
um
that made the military really easy
because I already shut off my feelings
you know and I think a lot of guys you
know maybe if they didn't shut them off
when they were a kid you know once they
start deploying they shut them off and
and then that again PTSD is when they've
been out long enough and the feelings
get turned back on and now there's a
backlog of emotion
um that that just comes flooding in and
and it doesn't
it doesn't I mean Emotion by definition
doesn't make sense it's not logical so
it's like how do you how do you
logically process something that's not
logical
you don't you just feel it I guess one
of the things too that I just like also
like knowing about you and then since
the documentary because like you said
like yeah just so much has changed since
and obviously you know and and so much
your life has changed it seems like your
personality is like so geared towards
you driving yourself but you also from
like your work in the military
um and now like what you're doing you're
such a team oriented person like you're
so good at like inspiring people helping
people building people up understanding
what people need to hear what they don't
need to hear you know the only way to
like deal with like deep psychological
uh blocks or problems or pts or whatever
the [__] you want to call it is like you
gotta you you can't do that alone like
you have to go to other people so it's
like those two things were kind of like
playing against each other would you say
that's right a hundred percent I I
I only did the documentary because Rick
was you know asked me and I said yeah
and then I imagine you you you were
hesitant no no I really wasn't
um
I I wasn't because it was just me
talking on camera about myself which I'm
doing right now I don't give a [__] I'll
tell you I'll tell you about the [__]
me as a kid at Camp I [__] my [__]
pants I don't care yeah yeah it happened
horrible day but I don't care you know
it doesn't I don't judge myself on
anything I've done or been and it's a
good diet man that's why you just judge
the campaign yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was a bad one too
um but the you know so I didn't have a
problem talking on camera
it was when it became something
and I first had I've only ever watched
it once and Rick [__] forced me to I
drank an entire bottle of wine and I
don't really drink a lot of alcohol and
watched it
um
and then when I had to like go and talk
about it with audiences and get asked
questions that's when
I got uncomfortable because I I don't
take compliments well you said some very
nice things I disagree with most of them
no and I'm joking but but I don't take
compliments well because that instinct
to push myself
I only hear I want I only want to hear
what I'm doing wrong it's the only way
to help tell me what I'm doing I don't
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah tell me when it
does nothing for you yeah and um and so
it was very hard to
to hear
people connecting with me because again
I shut off my feelings so a person
connecting
through my life was like really
uncomfortable for me and and so it was a
very strange
realization of oh I did this because
it's talking in front of a camera don't
really care and the the the other lesson
I learned from the documentary was
I need to put myself out there more and
I struggle with that every day and every
day I mean on Instagram I I just
actually started posting more in the
last I mean I'll go months and not post
something and the last like week I've
post like kind of a a message A Life
Lesson or something and every freaking
time I do every time I do at least one
person if not more will go thanks for
posting this I needed this or is that
what you posted about your dad I was
going to talk about I was like Yo dude
that that [__] really like I was
gonna thank you for but I know that's
also like yeah you don't really want to
hear that you know what I mean well no
it's I
I'm trying to get better at it well you
know like what I was going to say about
that too man is is you know what's so
inspirational for me and I mean you've
always been inspirational for me period
but like I I just think that like this
like acting [__] like art you know like
to save my life like I wasn't like in
theater troops yeah like I was like it
was not me bro yeah and uh there's a
risk and a danger to put yourself out
there and like being honest like whether
it's in front of a camera whether it's
in front of a stage or whether it's just
in front of people and it's like now man
it's like you're a professional artist
like that's like you're [__] the real
deal dude like you're [__] acting
your directions like you you know and um
you know real life and and our trauma
and and the [__] that we like that is
ultimately it's like you know it's like
that's that's our currency bro like
that's our that's like turning that into
positivity
touching other people putting ourselves
out like that [__] is like what it's
about because like ultimately I I just
know this but like we're not trying to
do this to like you know have a fancy
car or anything you know it's like we're
I we're trying to connect with people
we're trying to like put a put a label
to some sort of emotion or feeling that
someone else may have felt and and say
like hey man I feel this too that's
connectivity it's like why [__]
have been telling stories since they
were cavemen yeah I mean and that's what
we're after and like I'm wondering like
now being an artist or being in that
like doing this how has that made you
grown how has it changed you like like
what effect has it had so I really had
to uh
figure out you know what what it was
that attracted me to to film as a kid I
mean I remember being like seven and
walking around the track with my best
friend at the time and we would like
Siskel and Ebert movies you know I mean
we would break them down not just like
oh that was a cool you know like oh no
that scene was really good because
because yeah you know and and again uh
but what was it about film and and I've
really thought about it in the last
several years and I realized
I shut off my feelings as a kid the only
time I had allowed myself to feel is
when I was watching a movie well by
myself well you know like okay fine [__]
it I cried during notebook all right by
myself I watched it [__] you I held
everything in and nuked me you know but
um but but but it it was a safe place
for me because it wasn't about my
emotions like it was it was watching
something on screen so that's okay to be
you you can let out those emotions
because that they're not yours right and
so now for me everything I think of is
I I still have problems connecting in
person
but if I can put uh some art whether
it's uh you know on camera or behind the
camera or writing if it connects and and
helps someone understand themselves then
I'm I'm not connecting in person but I'm
connecting through that art and I I
don't think there's anything
at this point in my life I don't think
there's anything more important in the
world than art um
I I really don't
um I I don't think I agree with you I
don't think I would be alive if it
wasn't for art
um it's all I really aspire to do and
and uh you know the flip side which
obviously you'll know is you know we're
we're we work in a business that's a
business and you have to make somebody
money to make art
um which which is obviously difficult
but
um
I love the philosophical nature of of
you know who this character is and just
all this stuff like you really
ultimately film actually [__] it all art
is ultimately just about humans
connecting in The Human Experience all
it is you know whether it's sculpture
whatever it's it's just it's about being
human and and and really about being
emotional and uh about our emotions and
and I mean there is a logical component
to storytelling no question but I just
absolutely feel like quite frankly I
feel like it's important
um and as a as a veteran
um
I want to tell veteran stories that I
feel
um what I know about what I've been
through you know uh I tell people this
all the time I'm like despite what
anyone tells you and I actually when I
was at the the agency I actually said
this inside there like I don't care what
you guys say Hollywood is the largest
psyops campaign in the world and they
were they didn't like that uh and they
didn't think it was as funny as I did
yeah yeah I was like that's hilarious
you know they're like
but um but I really it is and and and
the ability for me to get out a message
that I think can help people I mean
that's what that's the at least the the
the the the Hope
um with this industry is is putting out
things that really help people or or
connect them or make them think about uh
things they haven't thought of about
themselves Etc and I
um
and then I guess there's entertaining
too I'm so I'm so curious though because
you talked a little bit about go about
you know talking to your shrink and
you're in just the disconnect between
what you're trying to read in the book
and your own lived experience and how
that Chasm could kind of never be
bridged so so talk about that in terms
of working in Hollywood right where like
you have this lived experience out in
the real world where there may be one
other person on the set of anybody who
has that shared experience that you had
yet all these people are trying to
recreate a reality that frankly only you
know
does that make you this just like do you
have to just say eventually like I gotta
let it go because they can't get it
exactly right or how do you process
through that when you're working that's
a that's a great question
um
and I'll I'll say it this way the
the difference
um so you know I've brought in several
people in into the industry
um military people that that I was like
hey you know they were interested or I
was just trying Hey you know whatever
and and I've had them be advisors and
and
then that happens to where they
can't adjust to the process of how film
is made
um no no it has to be this way it
doesn't have to be anyway
um
for me anything I was advising was never
about advising the military it was
creating the art I I love uh
you know working with with good actors
because no one will listen to you more
intently than a really good actor just
like and like it's like a vacuum just
taking it all in it's pretty impressive
um but also it's it's just the the the
awareness of conversation you know it's
like you tell them something and they go
from here to here not experiencing it
themselves and they go well I imagine if
this then
but anyway
how the [__] did you put that talk about
that psychopath [__] like how did you
put that together how did you make that
jump you didn't experience it yourself I
didn't I didn't tell you the in between
and they just they get it and it's
really
um the the quality that the you know
A-list actors like yourself have is this
innate ability to just a curiosity this
curiosity but just this innate
understanding of
of of humans and and emotions and and
it's just it's really
and it's not taught
it's not taught you either it's
something intrinsic inside you like it
you have it or you don't and obviously
it's like it's like an Olympian right
Michael Phelps you know is Michael
Phelps because his body is Michael
Phelps and then he trained his ass off
you know it's like there ain't no way I
don't float there's no way if I train
like Michael Phelps I would be an
Olympian and you got to have both
components so he grew up with me bro so
like any everybody who I grew up with
thinks acting is a [__] you ain't
gonna get no compliments on that he's
like oh [__] I'm just gonna say you know
we have a 35-year track record of never
complimenting each other yeah so I was
about to utter a company oh man yeah I
can squeeze it but I'm gonna try here
yeah and I was gonna say like what you
said about actors really listening is
also I think why you've gotten so much
joy out of this podcast definitely is
because having these conversations like
you are so equipped to live in the
moment of a conversation like this and
extract everything of value out of it
um and I think that's that's why this
has been so enjoyable for you and why
you put so much time into it
I I just I'm just proud that I could
that somehow I was a catalyst for that
moment I'm very happy yeah let's check
that off uh uh I'm just wondering just
from uh your your perspective totally
different
um you know you know what one of the
things we've done is like you know like
I I lived in in Russia for a couple
years it's like where I studied and [__]
I still have a bunch of friends over
there and friends in the Ukraine and
stuff I'm just wondering from your
perspective like what's your do you have
a take on that or like how do you feel
about it like that the for what's going
on yeah
um
so it would the best way to say it would
be you know my take on it going back to
our earlier conversation my take on it
three four years ago would have been
about 10 years ago it would have been
very different than than it is now
um now I I it just makes me sad and it
and it makes me sad because
you know it's very easy it's very easy
not having been in any of those shoes
it's very easy for someone to go yeah
[__] the Russians [__] ukrainians
kill them all and don't get me wrong
I understand that mentality and and
there's truth to it the flip side is
you know I guarantee most of those
Russians on the ground don't want to be
there and and and and and and are you
know essentially uh conscripted and
forced to be in that position uh and and
they're getting slaughtered you know the
the ukrainians are like dude you're
invading my country [__] you get out you
know it's like when I was in Iraq and I
would tell the Iraq the bad guys through
interpreters I'd be like look dude you
want to [__] shoot me you want to
blow me up
cool I get it I'm in your country if you
were in my country I'd kill the [__] out
of you yeah like we're square like I'm
cool on that like I have no issue with
you trying to kill me
you blowing up your women and children
to kill some of my guys I wouldn't do
that and I don't agree with that but uh
going back to to Ukraine it's it's
again it's just it's it's the system
it's politics and and again it you just
see it it's just it's so obvious and it
It's just sad that you know it's 2022
and we're like uh it's so different than
it was you know 1100 but are we really
that different than kings queens ponds
surfs like are we really that different
noblemen
really no
it's just humans it's the way we're
designed and it's it's sadly sadly we
keep denying
um our fundamental nature and I I think
that's what's hurting Society right now
is this fundamental denial of
that were actually [__] dark
creatures
and the more you deny it the more evil
things you can do because you're lying
to yourself that you're that you don't
have a dark side but you do
um and you know
that can be seen daily you know it can
be seen when you get cut off in traffic
you know [__] you I got in my way first
okay that's a micro analogy for let's
say there's only so much food right
like during the pandemic [__] you that's
those are my toilet paper yeah you know
what I mean it's it's we're designed
that way and we don't need to judge it
you know we just need to accept it and
and and
you know
um I I just I'm I'm sad that
that it got to the point where it
actually it actually happened and they
actually invaded and uh and it and they
haven't pulled out yet I mean that's
just
it
it worries me as a not as a country it
worries me as a world that there hasn't
been enough leverage to pull Russia out
of the Ukraine
the world's getting weirder I mean we're
approaching so many times that are
unprecedented in the history of of
mankind like as an example
okay uh Ukraine Russia did
you know did he use conscripts and and
you know push him yes so he still had to
get people you know to to to go
um but we're not far away
from a person being able to wage war
without another human right
that's insane I mean it's never happened
before and and we're not far from it in
fact I'd say it's it's possible right
now it's it's I'm sure laboratory
possible and I don't think people are
aware how fast things are going to
change they're already changing fast but
it's an exponential curve
um and it's changing faster than people
can accept and process and it's only
going to get faster going back to
therapy too it's there's this therapy
called uh radical acceptance I believe
it is where you're just like no no no
and then at a certain point you go oh my
God and then you just like accept
everything at one time you know I I
actually had that moment where I was
just miserable and and this will segue
to this is about a year ago and I was
just miserable and I I
I just wasn't happy and everything was I
just I just it's just angry all the time
all these things and
I'm like [__] man what how did I get
here again self-aware like how how did I
get here and
I thought about it and I can only come
up with one logical conclusion
and that was
what if everything I thought was wrong
what if everything that I've denied
is actually true
and what I denied for a long time is any
form of spirituality
I'm not a religious person but I just
deny that again and I shut off my
feelings shut off that you know
I'm like well what if there's something
to that you know and I just and it's
just so crazy how how you can
fundamentally
live your life for so long and then one
day realize that you know you're you're
wrong about so much you know and and the
fact is it's a fact that right now
everything we're talking about it won't
probably be wrong but we'll know a lot
more about it in five years and and then
we'll look back and go oh my God we were
so naive then yeah the smartest you are
in your entire life is the day you die
yeah yeah how [__] up is that yeah you
know kind of a downer sorry
my bad
um I appreciate you guys let me sitting
on this dude absolutely it was a
pleasure to meet you yeah same and and
it was great to have you and and it was
even uh that one moment was just the
best so I'm glad it happened glad I was
here for that too yeah okay can I ask
you a couple more questions is that cool
dude of course man I agree okay thank
you later bro do you now or at any point
in your life like have you felt like
you've had like a spiritual spiritual
connection or
you know I
when I put effort into it last year when
I had time I'm not a religious person
I was at this place and they were
talking about spirituality and they're
like you know it doesn't you know it can
be whatever I forget where they called
it your spiritual whatever and I used
the the universe you know and the reason
is is I definitely didn't create it I
don't control it I know it exists so
okay the universe will be my you know my
my spirit uh animal for for lack of a
better term and it it definitely did
something and and it was interesting
because I couldn't tell you
how or why but it I think what it did
was it it subconsciously took a little
bit of my need to control away
um
and I I didn't realize how much that I
I had a a problem with with control yeah
but but it's also it's like a shift from
it's a [__] from controlling to to
behaving I don't know I I look at the
times in my life that like trying to
connect to something bigger I've always
been really envious of people who who
have like a pretty rich or like at least
coaching spiritual life yeah I feel like
it like helps them you know like in some
ways I'm the same way you've been in
some in incredibly
I want to use the word tremend like
you've been in [__] super super
[__] high pressure situations were
you talking to anybody in those moments
was there anybody like I'm I'm I'm
honestly so glad you asked that question
uh because it's again I I think an
interesting story so um and I don't know
if I've ever told it
um so when I got blown up I had an
arterial bleed so
um from my uh
ulna artery was bleeding
um and uh so you know it gives you about
I mean it depends and again some doctors
can be like [__] you you're wrong with
it you know you have a couple minutes
did you know that
um not at first at first I thought my
arm was blown off I I because I could
feel it gone I know that sounds weird
but it felt not there
um and because it blew my nods off so I
couldn't see everything was dark in the
house there was a gunfight going on I
couldn't hear anything you know
um but when I eventually got outside the
house there was a like a [__] porch
light on and that was the first time I
looked at it and it was [__]
hamburger meat
um and then it was what it was hamburger
meat I mean it was just it was broken in
so many places that it wasn't just like
Twisted it was like it was I don't know
how they saved it but it was mangled it
it literally looked
fake
but I noticed that I was bleeding pretty
profusely and then there was a a wall
like you know and I just looked at it
I'm like well that ain't [__]
happening you know like I'm not getting
over that
um and
I think I maybe at that point lost
Consciousness for a minute or two I
remember just plopping against the wall
but anyways I um well at first I
remember thinking okay my arm is
definitely gone it's [__] gone like
[__] goodbye have a good one
um I'm gonna be an armless vet and I
just I just remember this like whole
process in my head of thinking God I'm a
one arm and just like flashes of Vietnam
veterans you know were in my head and
and then I'm like all right and I kind
of accepted that and then then I
remember going oh whoa wait a minute
you might die
and I was like oh [__] yeah like and
it's within you know a couple seconds I
was like holy [__] you might die from
this like
you gotta fix this and I'm like yeah you
don't want to die from this is it that'd
be [__] stupid and then when um uh
one guy got to me uh which and this is
just [__]
Cosmic Stardust the guy that comes and
puts the tourniquet on my arm
is the guy who I was with on that
mission in Afghanistan when I was a
ranger
what are the odds of that
so I'm there and I'm and I'm laying
there and I'm I'm which which guy from
from I remember when I said I worked
with the unit I wanted to go to and they
were selecting their own targets and
doing stuff in Afghanistan yeah when I
was a ranger yeah that guy cut to I'm in
his unit now wow and he's the one who
put the tourniquet on my arm wow the guy
you're like I want to do that yeah what
are the odds you know years later
um and so I uh
but I'm I'm there and I'm and I and it
just kind of occurs to me that you know
[__] I I might die and and people were
working on on me but you know you don't
know it's hard to gauge you know uh you
know it's bad but like again you don't
and and are the guys that I mean you
were shot at oh there's a gunfight going
on in the house right so I mean has that
been dealt with yet or uh I
no I think it was still going on they
were still fighting yeah it was a lot of
it was a lot of guys
um but um
so anyways uh I'm laying there and I'm
like oh [__] I I might die and then it
just kind of hits me I'm like [__]
I'm I might actually die oh my God like
this is when religion comes and I'm like
I'm in this you know pain I'm in this
[__] up situation I'm like kind of
excited like again Human Experience
experiment I'm like all right like come
on religion like you know are you guys
where are you at where you at yeah I'm
like laying there and I'm like yeah yeah
I'm like
all right you know how do I feel and I
just started like kind of going through
the process and
and I'm like nope still still nothing
like I and I legitimately thought I
could die and I just was like I just I
don't have it it just wasn't
it wasn't there and and it's because I
wasn't open to it obviously you know I'm
not a I'm not a fool it was it was I was
expecting something to like hit me over
the head and you know and again it's the
people that are open to that concept and
all those things it comes to them the
people that it's just like I go to a I
don't believe in ghost and I go to a
freaking ghost house and I sleep there
and well shockingly I slept through the
night and had no [__] problems weird
right oh they must have not come out
that night no it's that I don't [__]
care you know and um and so it's one of
those things where it kind of
disappointed me to be perfectly honest
it kind of
and again it was my lack of you know but
I I was I was hoping that I was gonna
have some kind of like sense of
some kind of next step and I just didn't
I just felt like I was just gonna die
right there in the [__] mud and
[__] [__] in solder City shanty
town like I just I didn't have a good
feeling about it I I had like how
[__] stupid would it be if I [__]
died right here in the in the mud laying
down it just like kind of disgusted me
you know what I mean it didn't feel
honorable to you know what I mean it
didn't feel like I thought it should
feel it's like going out on the
battlefield you know like Lieutenant Dan
you know like it just felt like if you
experience anything like that now do you
feel like it would be different I don't
know if that's an answerable question
but you know
I would hope
I I would hope
um I definitely have
a different spiritual belief
um now I the simple way to explain my
spirituality is I don't know what it is
but there's something bigger than me
yeah I know that yeah I don't know what
it is yeah it's a fact that I don't
[__] know yeah but it's proof that
there's gotta be because I didn't
[__] create myself so that's kind of
where I'm at so I would hope it would be
different and and
um but yeah I've always been jealous of
people that are on that spiritual
wavelength to where it's just a real
connection right now you have so much to
say like right now you have so much to
do like you have so much work like you
have so much [__] that you want to do
and accomplish it just seems like
you know when I I don't know man it just
seems to me so much of like your
psychology back then was like [__]
turtle
shutting everything off and now it's
about trying to open up and and
you know the other thing I mean I was
just a sad kid you know I was I was a
kid where they would uh you know go like
Hey we're gonna go toilet paper Mr John
old Mr Johnson's house and you know I
was like [__] seven eight nine and
I'd be like
why I don't want to do that he'll have
to pick it up and they're like what the
[__] are you talking you know I'm like
that would be sad watching old man John
and it just like and they're like
[__] [__] [__] you know you know
it just discomfort is growth and I
wanted that discussion is that bucket is
that a bucket that you feel like is
filled with like have you filled that
bucket or is that is that does that go
forward it's a struggle you know I hear
you bro it's a struggle that's a daily
struggle and because
again I I can see where you know there's
a lot to
um self-care and all these different
things but
there hasn't been a time that I haven't
done something extremely
self-destructive
that I didn't learn something from and
and that I didn't
really gain from the experience and and
you know you're kind of it's like
balancing is like is it worth it you
know and um
and I just have this fundamental need
sometimes and again going back to what I
said way earlier which is about
acceptance of self like I have finally
had to accept that at a certain level I
crave self-destruction
I just do and
I accept it
um and I had to accept it because if I
pretended it wasn't there
it would it it would happen you know
without me really being you know I would
just go into that mode so I just like it
look man again you know I'm I'm super
interested in that and I think that's
also not being
not sound like a [__] douchebag but
it's kind of like the artist's Journey
too it's like I I believe something you
know we talked about him earlier
something shy and I kind of argue about
all the time like this this need to like
bleed out I don't know if that's the
same but can you give me an example of
like the last time or something recently
you felt like you've done that was
self-destructive
um
usually my self-destructive Behavior was
with
was with women quite frankly uh I mean I
partied in Vegas with strippers for like
two years straight it was [__]
literally all I did you know
um and and that's a crazy lifestyle and
and it was a destructive lifestyle and
it and again it was how much can I
destroy myself
and still bring myself back
what level of Destruction can I go to
and still come back from it and I
haven't found it
and I know what it is it's [__] death
obviously
um
but how close could I get to that it's a
perverted sense of of
self-challenge challenge challenge yeah
and this that cycle but is there a way
you can channel that into work and and
that's what I've been doing and that's
what I've been doing I've I've been much
better like the last I I finally
realized that that about a year ago that
that self-destruction and that I was
attracted to that destruction like that
girl's [__] crazy let me give her a
call let me take her out you know like
hey those friends you shouldn't hang out
with them [__] come on guys you know
like that was just what I was 100 the
way it was and um and and you know like
a good example would be a again not that
I know specifics at all but commonly
mentioned about Heath Ledger and and his
process for the Joker and all all these
things it's it's very it's just to me
it's a similar mentality of of
self-destruction and and the problem is
society or people that don't have that
it doesn't make sense so when you're you
know that way uh in your normal life and
you see self-destructive Behavior people
are like you know in the military and
the reason I bring it up the military is
is because it's being you know they're
they're just wrecking dudes for getting
DUIs getting you know dude what the [__]
are you doing speeding 112 20 miles an
hour well because they were trying to
get some adrenaline once you've been at
this level of adrenaline and you go home
like
once you've been shot at in close
proximity yeah well you know how are you
going to replicate that you know buy a
new motorcycle and go 130 miles an hour
you know it's like okay uh man maybe
I'll get the cops to chase me [__] it I
don't care because I'm trying to I'm
you're chasing the dragon of Destruction
no different than chasing the dragon on
a drug because despite what most people
say adrenaline is an addictive [__]
drug absolutely and once you've got it
you're always looking for it again
you know I did see that post that you
put up on your pop and then like tying
it into you you know that that little
part of the documentary and stuff it's
like what can you just like where are
you guys at and like what what is your
relationship with your dad if you don't
mind me asking
so
my dad uh my dad had is an alcoholic his
always been an alcoholic guy I knew he
was an alcoholic when I was you know
[__] five six years old
um you know two or three years ago I had
to bail my dad out of jail on New Year's
Eve for a DUI he's [__] 72 years old
you know
um but I hated him I hated him because
he was a shitty dad I mean you know
um
I just wanted someone to take me hunting
and shooting and you know he just drank
and passed out and and again you know
it's not like you [__] beat me up but
you know it's it's many kids had many
worse childhoods don't get me wrong
um
but I just I didn't really
uh I hated him you know
um and then when I was forced to to
you know he because of his drinking my
mom divorced him he you know didn't have
a place he got into a car accident
drinking and driving lost his vehicle
didn't have a place to live so I let him
move into my house and um
and you know I
it was scary how many things I saw
uh in him that
that our qualities in me and and I hate
those qualities about him and so then
when I realized that I do him [__] it
was like a slap in the face because I I
realized like I do those things you know
you know what I mean like
um one would just be you know
like immediately being defensive if you
say something I'm oh I know you know
like
like immediately trying to to say
something's not my fault like he you
know he always does that and it's like
and it could just be your it's not about
whose fault it is you're just trying to
express your feelings about something or
whatever but it made me understand him
um and it made me realize that my
struggles were also his struggles and
that I just I've got to get over the
past and I shouldn't I shouldn't judge
him on on anything and
um and and now too I you know I went
through a period where I wanted a dad I
want I wanted him to stop drinking and
and uh
and then I just
finally realized like
he'll never stop drinking like he's how
it hasn't killed him
to be perfectly honest he should be
[__] studied by science because I I
don't know how he's not dead but but um
but I finally just had to accept him for
who he is he's an alcoholic he'll always
be an alcoholic alcohol will kill him
and
I just have to accept that and that
doesn't change the fact that he's my dad
and I'll always love him for that
um
I I accept him as as who he is I accept
his dark side and in that was in that
process was
again me learning to accept my own you
know my self-destruction comes from him
yeah and I have absolutely no doubt my
dad would have been happy and again this
is so [__] up but it's true my dad
my Dad's life would have been complete
had he gone to Vietnam and died that's
what he wishes his life was Wow
when he was at my house he'd watch
[__] Vietnam documentaries literally
all day long interviews just non-stop he
had a hernia which is why I didn't go to
Vietnam and he just again it's like he
wants to he wanted to go and either come
back [__] up or come back or not come
back and it's and I'm like listening to
this stuff I'm like that's
he didn't even go to Vietnam why the
[__] is he and I slowly put it together
it's like there's just something
there's just something in him it's the
same thing in me and
we don't choose it
but to deny it's there is to deny who we
are [__] hate you know and and
knowing it is like ever you know
especially as an artist man knowing that
everything like you know everything and
that Reckless abandon that you're
talking about though that's
that's positive destruction a dude you
know dude Yes Man positive super power
and I think I I would even go as far as
say like the darker you can go
the deeper into the wound like I was
saying that you could go into yourself
and like to do that
even if it costs party it's actually
I mean such a [__] lame word but it's
super [__] therapeutic you know I
mean it's such a [__] word but it's
like you actually are like yo and then
you're like I left that I did that
actually like I pulled out something
from me that that has only led to like
destruction violence Mayhem betrayal
awfulness vileness and I like pulled it
out of me in like a [__] actually
safe way where I wasn't actually hurting
anybody yeah and like this will somebody
will see it big yo man I I know that
like I [__] [__] I see that I'm I'm
really really [__] excited to see you
know like what this this next chapter of
your life is is gonna be man yeah yeah
it's yeah I mean
going to what you just said it's it's
really what I figured out is just
and I should have mentioned this earlier
but the the need for Destruction is not
going to change it's no it's about just
choosing positive destruction yeah and
uh and actually I could also replace the
word uh uh destruction with chaos okay
I've craved chaos because I'm
comfortable in chaos and there's few
things more [__] chaotic than than a
film set and yeah being you know being
on camera is [__] chaotic like yeah
um directing chaotic and and I love that
chaos I crave it I'm comfortable in it
and it's healthy chaos the fact that
you're gonna be able to like marry All
This and like that you're it's [__]
great
[Music]
all right
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with about their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we are
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I gonna have my son
Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones